Pogpog und Chat, was habe ich verpasst?
Nein, ist sogar schon jemand da
Instantsubbox gecampt. Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, es dauert wieder 2-3 Minuten
Bis Twitch das mitbekommen hat, dass der Stream on ist. Oder war das Zufall, dass ihr es noch irgendwie auf hattet?
Boah, Alter, was ist jetzt los? Instant irgendwie 500 Leute am Start. Was ist denn los?
Boah, wer haben wir hier am Start? Alles Ranon da, SlimBeatz, Destiny Wirks, weiß nicht, wie man das ausspricht, Kumpelmeister, TheCheese ist auch wieder da, TakeViagra am Start, ChessBots, Ot4Peak auch wieder da. Nice, lange nicht gesehen. Ja, glaube ich sofort.
Du hast ja auch sonst nichts zu tun, ne? So eigener Stream oder irgendwie sonst was. Brauchen wir nicht. Ganzen Tag, ganzen Tag subcampen, Beste.
An's Trinken erinnern. SlimBeatz, danke für den Sub.
Eine Lampe.
Mehr RGBs, please.
Ich hab auch mal, ich hab auch mal eine Lampe gebaut, aber sag mal, mit der könnte man prinzipiell auch sowas machen, weil die sich per Tasmota in die Heimautomatisierung verbinden lässt.
Guck mal, warte mal, guck mal, hier sieht man die Lampe. Die Lampe sieht aber ein bisschen kacke aus, aufgenommen.
Du hast WLED Extensions, oh, also okay, WLED Extensions, das ist cool, das hab ich noch nicht gemacht.
Ich hab mal, ich glaub, eine Tasmota Extension minimal erweitert, dass es einen Custom-Schalter hinbekommen hat, hab ich aber nie am Ende verwendet.
Die Lampe sieht aber ziemlich, ja, das sieht halt, das sieht kacke aus mit dem Handy aufgenommen.
Ich mein, im Endeffekt, die hab ich aber, die steht hier, die hab ich tatsächlich regelmäßig abends an, weil ich finde, ich finde ehrlich gesagt, das Licht von der ist sehr angenehm.
Es ist nicht so hell und ich brauch auch nicht meine Fenster-RGB-Beleuchtung anmachen.
Ja, man erkennt's halt, das liegt ja so ein bisschen am iPhone, das Aufgenommene, ja, dass das so kacke aussieht.
Aber im Endeffekt ist es ein 3D-gedrucktes Gehäuse mit so einer, glaub, was ist es, 32x32 oder so, LED-Matrix.
Eigentlich total easy.
Müsste ich mal wieder ein paar bestellen bei AliExpress.
AliExpress ist ziemlich teuer geworden teilweise mit dem Versand, die China-Chinesen.
Was? Mr. PC? Ah, nee.
M-Side to PC. Okay, ich hab Mr. PC gelesen.
Magst Bock auf Stellenanzeiger? Probearbeit. Ja, auf, schick her.
Ich wollte heute eigentlich nicht wieder, denn wir lesen den ganzen Abend Stellenanzeigen machen, aber wenn du was hast, schick her.
Ja, das Gute ist, wenn man einfach nur nakisches Tasmota nimmt und das in irgendwas integriert, äh, nicht Tasmota, was laber ich denn?
Äh, nakisches WLED nimmt und in irgendwas Fertiges integriert, dann muss man sich halt nicht um die ganzen Sachen kümmern.
Was ist eigentlich mit dem Fiat Champ? Der Fiat Champ hat keine Probleme, wie man hier sieht.
ESP Home is the shit? Hab ich auch schon benutzt. Keine Probleme.
Alles... Ich überleg gerade, warum ich hauptsächlich Tasmota als ESP...
Achso, äh, nee, warte mal. Weiß es gar nicht. Wahrscheinlich, weil es nochmal ein extra Webinterface hat?
E-Paper Display. Ich hab... Ich folge auf Twitter einem, der hat ein Projekt gebaut für E-Paper Displays mit so ganz billigen, die eigentlich für den Supermarkt gedacht sind, so wie ich das mitgekriegt hab.
Irgendwie so... Weißt du, diese Anzeigen im Supermarkt, die die Preise updaten können, das weiß ich nicht.
Ich mein den, der auch die Customfirma für die Xiaomi Thermometer gebaut hat ursprünglich.
Stimmt. Ne, ne, ne, ich bin...
Und zumindest ist das eigentlich mega nice. Du kriegst von Apple und Nike diese E-Paper Displays.
Systemadministrator Linux. Zeig mal her.
Twitter gibt's noch. Gerüchte folgen, ja. Gerüchte zu folgen, ja.
Ja, aufschick her. Let's go. Komm. Aber das machen wir heute nicht den ganzen Abend.
Ach, soll ich nur... Ich sag's nur gleich, ne.
Ich bin heute wieder übelst im Arsch. Es ist übrigens auf die Frage hin, wie die Arbeit war. Hat doch irgendjemand gefragt.
Irgendjemand hat doch gefragt, wie die Arbeit war. Bin ich jetzt blöd?
Achso, er hat sich einfach verschrieben, wie die Arbeit war. Die Arrebeit war.
Ähm, ich hab heute nicht gearbeitet.
Bernie, ich hab heute nicht gearbeitet.
No, no Arbeit.
Ich hab mir vorgenommen, das echt zu überarbeiten.
Das Problem ist, warum ich aktuell keinen Bock habe, an dem Projekt weiterzubauen, ist,
man könnte extrem viele coole Sachen machen. Das erstmal vorneweg, ja.
Also, nur mal kurz zu erklären, was das ist.
Das ist ein Smart Home, ein Add-On für Fiat Elektroautos,
beziehungsweise Fiat, Jeep, Ram, Dodge und Alfa Romeo.
Das sind eher so Ami-Dinger.
Wo man Sachen von seinem... Stats von seinem Elektroauto abfragen kann.
So, und ich bin... Darkseembroken.
Ich bin gerade etwas unmotivierter, daran weiterzuarbeiten.
Wie man ja auch hier sieht, die Leute haben das teilweise schon geforkt und sowas.
Weil es macht aktuell alles, was ich haben will.
Und, naja, ich bin halt zu faul, das zu updaten.
Man könnte richtig coole Sachen machen noch.
Man könnte auch das MQTT-Messaging einbauen von Amazon,
dass man beispielsweise mitkriegt, wenn das Auto irgendwelche Events schickt,
wie beispielsweise, ich bin jetzt im Parkhaus, ich bin jetzt auf der Arbeit,
ich bin jetzt so, man kann ja so Zonen setzen sogar.
Also, man könnte extrem viel wirklich super-nices Zeug machen,
aber ich bin gerade so faul dazu, da weiter dran zu bauen.
Weil, wenn ich das ordentlich bauen will,
ich muss da halt schon ziemlich viel mal überdenken, ja.
Wie man das macht am besten.
Und irgendwie fehlt mir gerade die Motivation dafür.
Was sollte ich mit Menschen machen, die von mir erwarten, unentgeltlich zum Probearbeiten?
Ich weiß nicht, ist es, ich kann dir das nicht sagen,
ist es üblich, Probearbeit wirklich zu arbeiten oder nennt man das einfach so?
Das ist doch eher so ein Tag angucken, ob man so miteinander klarkommt.
Ist das in der Regel bezahlt oder nicht?
Ich weiß es nicht, ich habe nie Probe gearbeitet in dem Sinn.
Ich habe das zwar mal geplant, dass ich das mal machen könnte,
aber ja, habe ich nicht.
Ja, ich denke schon, dass ein Home Assistant Add-on durchaus ein gutes Einsteigerprojekt sein kann,
wenn man denn ein bisschen hartnäckig ist und dran bleibt.
Home Assistant Add-ons selber sind relativ easy,
wobei man das unterscheiden muss zwischen Plugins und Add-ons.
Plugins sind in Python relativ easy,
Add-ons sind eigene Docker-Container, die parallel gestartet werden
und auch nur in der Home Assistant OS-Variante funktionieren,
die 95% der Leute benutzen.
Also ja, aber wenn du so ein Python-Plugin für Home Assistant bauen willst,
ist das, glaube ich, sogar ein ganz gutes Einsteigerprojekt,
wenn man sich da ein bisschen reinbeißt,
weil das ist nicht so schwer und es gibt gute Tutorials für.
Natürlich, das dann am Ende zu machen, was du machen willst,
das kann sich dann doch als schwer gestalten.
Ich weiß ja nicht, was du vorhast.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine sinnvolle Idee, mit etwas anzufangen,
wo man selbst so ein bisschen invested ist, ja?
Also es ist immer langweilig, Hello-World-Projekte zu machen
oder irgendwelche...
Das ist mir zu hell.
Irgendwelche To-Do-Listen und Blödsinn zu machen, ja?
Das ist immer übelst langweilig.
Wenn man eine Projektidee hat, was man halt auch braucht,
dann ist die Motivation meistens auch etwas höher,
sich da reinzubeißen, ja?
Das mache ich nicht auf.
Wer weiß, wo ich da raufkomme, wenn ich auf diese Uhr klicke, Alter.
Warte mal, ich muss mal meine Nilux-VrM als Vorschau öffnen.
Bad Request, okay, funktioniert auch gar nicht.
Ist Brocken.
Wahrscheinlich, weil du irgendwie deine Session-ID oder so mitgeliefert hast.
Das geht so nicht.
Wie hast du das Kubernetes-Problem bei der Arbeit gelöst?
Okay, okay, okay, also.
Es war ja schon fies von mir, das im Video so zu teasern,
aber ich habe das, glaube ich, die letzten zwei Streams
immer schon mal wieder erklärt.
Deswegen, ich glaube, wir haben sogar,
haben wir nicht dafür sogar ein Chat-Kommando?
Für die Kubernetes-Sache mittlerweile?
Hatten wir nicht letztens?
Wir hatten doch letztens für irgendwelche Sachen,
die ich auf die Schnelle erklärt habe, ein Chat-Kommando gemacht.
Ist da Max da?
FiveHeadModge?
Du hast doch letztens ein Chat-Kommando gebaut.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es für das Kubernetes-Problem war.
Irgendwas war das, wo ich mir gedacht habe,
gut, dass wir dafür mal ein Chat-Kommando haben.
Ach, für Battle.Bit, okay.
Nee, dann meinte ich das.
Alfred, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Also, auf die Schnelle.
Ich erkläre dir mal.
Ich mache mal kurz ein Update von meiner VM.
Und während ich ein Update baue von der VM,
ein Update, also während ich ein Update baue,
ich habe gerade die Chat-Message gelesen,
während ich ein Update mache von meiner VM,
kann ich dir ganz kurz erzählen, um was es da ging.
Das machen wir jetzt wirklich sehr zackig.
Also, das Problem bei Kubernetes war Folgendes.
Also, ganz kurz und knackig.
kubectl, also wir sind bei Google Cloud
und benutzen Google Kubernetes Engine.
Also, wenn man kubectl aufruft,
dann ruft das wiederum ein Google-Authentifizierungs-Plugin auf.
Das Google-Authentifizierungs-Plugin
ruft wiederum die Google-G-Cloud-Command-Line-Tool auf.
Das G-Cloud-Command-Line-Tool möchte ins Internet gehen
und von dort Sachen abrufen.
Es darf aber nicht ins Internet gehen,
weil der Rechner keinen Internetzugang hat.
Das heißt, entweder muss man eine Proxy setzen
oder man macht das, was uns Google geraten hat,
nämlich irgendwelche semi-offiziellen Parameter zu setzen.
Und damit geht das.
Und warum das Ganze hängt, ist folgendermaßen,
die verwenden unter der Haube curl.
Curl hat standardmäßig einen Timeout von zwei Minuten
und die Antworten werden dann von dem Programm 15 Minuten lang gecached.
Deswegen hängt es alle 15 Minuten für jeweils zwei Minuten.
Und warum hängt es?
Weil unsere Firewall die Pakete droppt, anstatt sie zu rejecten.
Aber das eigentliche Problem ist,
dass das G-Cloud-CLI irgendeine Features-JSON aus dem Internet abrufen will,
das nicht darf.
Und das will das machen, um zu überprüfen,
ob die Version, die man verwendet, aktuell ist.
So, das war jetzt kurz und knackig.
Das können wir auch mal klippen und gleich ein Kommando draus machen.
Das kommt wahrscheinlich so oft noch,
weil ich es im Video gesagt habe.
Ja, Moment.
Also eine Woche oder zwei ist für mich kein Probearbeiten.
Ich meine sowas wie,
sich mal das Team angucken und mal vor Ort das Ganze anschauen,
einen Tag oder einen halben Tag,
da wird nicht richtig gearbeitet.
Aber zwei Wochen, das ist ja schon quasi eine halbe Anstellung.
Mich würde übrigens auch wundern,
wenn das überhaupt erlaubt ist,
die Leute für zwei Wochen quasi ohne Versicherung,
ohne Bezahlung, ohne alles zu beschäftigen.
Da muss es einen Vertrag für geben.
Ich meine, okay, ohne Bezahlung ist erlaubt,
wenn beide Seiten zustimmen wahrscheinlich.
Aber trotzdem glaube ich nicht,
dass das irgendwie so praktiziert wird.
Du hast null Ahnung von Programmieren.
Ja, wenn du null Ahnung von Programmieren hast,
aber dich gerne damit beschäftigen willst
und auch so ein bisschen ein Auge vielleicht
auf Heimatomatisierung und Python geworfen hast,
ist das ein ganz gutes Einstiegsprojekt.
Du musst halt ein bisschen,
nicht stressresistent,
aber ein bisschen fehlertolerant sein,
weil du musst ja dann quasi Python lernen,
die Home Assistant, AP lernen
und wie man Add-ons entwickelt,
beziehungsweise Plug-ins sind es ja eigentlich.
Ist aber gar nicht schlecht.
Also ich finde, es ist ein gutes Einstiegsprojekt.
Hast du eigentlich schon den Namen
von dem neuen Video-Editor?
Du meinst ClipChamp?
Ja, habe ich.
Könnte von mir sein.
Passt.
Wir machen mal kurz Package-Updates.
Yes, yes, yes.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Es ist ein gutes Anfängerprojekt.
Man könnte ja als Home Assistant-Plugin,
du kannst ja mit etwas Simplem anfangen.
So, mach dem Motto, es registriert sich
und dann machst du einen Button,
was dann einfach State von A nach B triggert
und dann machst du eine Anzeige im Web-UI.
Das Web-UI ist ja von Home Assistant
standardmäßig drin.
Es musst du ja nicht programmieren.
Man baut ja da quasi eher so Backend-Services,
die dann irgendwas steuern.
Ja, ich finde es ein ganz gutes Anfängerprojekt.
Aber man muss ein bisschen
federtolerant sein.
Ah, nicer Clip.
Ja, das trifft es ganz gut.
Das ist ja fast so schlecht
wie das,
was mir gestern eingefallen ist.
Ob ein 8er Squad im Battle-Bit
das dann zu einem Battle-Bit macht.
Hypernob!
Danke für den Sub.
Also, Let's Player-Gear.
Ich versuche dir mal was dazu
zu erzählen.
Achso, ich habe dazu übrigens auch mal
ein Video gemacht.
Hier.
Was heißt ich? Wir haben da ein Video zu gemacht.
Bei mir auf dem Channel
und bei ihm auf dem Channel ist exakt das gleiche Video.
Ist egal, wo du es guckst.
Da kannst du natürlich auch gerne da gucken.
Wir haben ein Video dazu gemacht, wo wir uns ausgelassen haben
zu dem Thema, mit welcher Programmiersprache
man anfangen soll.
Mein Tipp war
entweder Go oder Python
oder JavaScript.
Das würde ich keinem empfehlen.
Ich konnte es dem Florian aber nicht
ausreden.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, warum er...
Keine Ahnung, ich konnte es ihm nicht ausreden.
Ich bin nicht der Meinung,
das ist ein guter Einstiegsfrager.
Java oder C-Sharp.
Also diese
vier Sachen würde ich
empfehlen.
Java ist auch in Ordnung. Ich persönlich bin aber
eher im C-Sharp Land
unterwegs. Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt auf Java
keinen Bock hätte, wenn ich JVM entwickeln würde.
Dann wahrscheinlich Kotlin.
Das sah mir noch am sympathischsten aus.
Also das kannst du dir mal angucken,
das Video, wenn es dich interessiert.
Also ich persönlich würde dir empfehlen,
wenn du eine Idee hast für ein Projekt
und wenn es das Home Assistant Add-on ist,
dann mach das und dann musst du mit Python
anfangen, was auch eine super Einstiegsprogrammier-Sprache
ist, sonst hätten wir das nicht im Video.
Also ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass das hier das Erste, die Beste
ist, das Letzte, die Schlechte. Das ist alles
gleichberechtigt. Das Beste, was dir passieren
kann, ist, du hast eine
Vorstellung, was du machen willst. Dann nimm
Python als Einstiegssprache
und in der heutigen Zeit ist es eines der meist
gefragten, wenn nicht die meist gefragte Sprache
überhaupt. Naja, nee.
Im Business-Enterprise-Umfeld
insgesamt würde ich sagen, dürfte es immer
noch Java sein, aber
insgesamt ist es sicherlich eines der
angesagtesten Sprachen überhaupt.
Und wenn dir das nicht
zusagt, aber du dich trotzdem ein bisschen mit Programmieren
beschäftigen willst, dann kann
ich dir nur empfehlen, probier es mal mit
JavaScript. Weil JavaScript ist der
Einstieg mit Abstand am einfachsten.
Du brauchst einen Text-Editor,
du brauchst einen Browser und das
war's.
Das hat jeder auf dem Rechner.
Ich meine, ich würde nicht empfehlen, mit Notepad
anzufangen. Lieber gleich Visual
Studio Code, weil Notepad ist halt so ein Ding.
Notepad...
Leute haben in der Berufsschule
teilweise Notepad benutzt, um irgendwas zu
programmieren oder Datenbank-Sachen zu schreiben,
wo ich mir immer gedacht habe, Leute, was ist mit
euch verkehrt? Wobei wir hatten auch
in der Klasse Leute, die haben
2 von 100 Punkten in der Datenbank-Arbeit
bekommen, weil sie zweimal Create Table geschrieben
haben. Das ist kein Witz,
Leute.
Zweimal Create Table, 2 Punkte
von 100. Das war
echt nicht seine Ausbildung
von... Ja, ich sag jetzt
seinen Namen nicht, aber
das war
nicht sein Job. Dabei
also der Typ, der es geschafft hat,
2 von 100 Punkten in der Datenbank-Arbeit zu
schreiben, dabei ist das eigentlich
eine recht tragische Geschichte,
wie er zur Physiausbildung gekommen ist.
Und zwar, der war früher
Steinmetz. Ich glaube, ich hab das schon mal erzählt.
Und
ich glaube, da war er auch
voll in seinem Element, ja.
Aber
dem ist...
Moment, so, ähm, genau.
Also der war früher Steinmetz und dem
ist, während er dort halt als
Steinmetz gesteinmetzt hat,
ist ihm irgendeine schwere
Platte auf den Fuß gefallen,
sodass er seitdem Probleme hatte, irgendwie
frag mich nicht
richtig aufzutreten oder so, auf der
einen Seite. Zumindest, der konnte
durch den Unfall quasi seinen,
ja, wahrscheinlich Lieblingsberuf,
der war Steinmetz, nicht mal ausüben.
Und der Chef von seinem
alten Betrieb hat gesagt, ey, weißt du was?
Ich kenn da jemand
mit einer Firma, die Computerzeug
macht. Willst du nicht umsatteln?
Auf Fachinformatiker
Systemintegration. Also sein
alter Chef, dort wo er den Unfall hatte,
was man ihm ja auch mal echt anrechnen
muss, denke ich. Hat ihm halt die Ausbildung
quasi vermittelt. Problem war
halt, Fachinformatiker war
überhaupt nicht sein
Ding. Das war gar nicht
seins. Der war bestimmt ein super
Steinmetz, aber
kein guter Physi.
Ist auch der einzige aus meiner
Klasse, den ich kenne, der durchgefallen ist
in der Abschlussprüfung.
Aber ich glaube, ich glaube, der hat's da nochmal gemacht
und dann hat er's geschafft. Ich weiß es gar
nicht genau. Also
dabei,
das war auch noch gleichzeitig so
so ganz, okay
kennt ihr Leute so?
Neben denen
sitzt ihr drei Jahre in der Berufsschule
und ihr labert auch ab und zu mal so ein bisschen, aber
irgendwie wisst ihr über die Leute nix, ja?
Und manchmal
erfahrt ihr dann was über die Leute
und das ist eigentlich übertrieben
nice und du denkst dir so,
warum hat denn der Typ das nie erzählt?
Ja, zum Beispiel
zum Beispiel, dass der wohl
auch irgendwie, ich
hab mich immer gewundert, ja?
Warum der immer so
viel unterwegs ist und was da los ist?
Der war irgendwie Coach
oder so in der
frag mich
in der deutschen Ruder
Nationalmannschaft oder sowas
nebenbei noch. Der war immer auf
irgendwelchen Training-Camps
und sowas unterwegs und der hat
nie ein Wort darüber erzählt,
bis ich irgendwann mal
erkannt hab so, ja, ich war jetzt letztens
in Peru oder so.
Alter, was machst du in Peru?
Ja, so Rudern
Alter, hättest die letzten
zwei Jahre mal was erzählen können von
Modcheck
könnte das einer als
CubeCTL-Command reinmachen von den
Modgis
Max, glaubst du
dass, ne Max,
glaubst du, dass asiatische Softwareentwickler
im Allgemeinen
die besseren Entwickler sind oder gibt es
von ihnen einfach mehr?
Naja, es gibt doch so den alten Spruch, egal wie
gut du was kannst, es gibt immer ein Asiater, der es besser
kann.
Ist das jetzt auch schon
Racism heutzutage?
Ne, das ist ja quasi, oder ist das jetzt
positiv Racism?
Man gibt ja für alles irgendwelche komischen Wörter
mittlerweile. Also
realistisch betrachtet würde ich sagen
Ja und nein
Ich wollte übrigens
irgendwas bei AliExpress machen gerade, aber ich bin
Ich finde es nicht mehr
Leute, ich blick
ich blick nicht mehr durch
es ist zu voll
Ich muss glaube ich mal ein bisschen was zumachen
Irgendwas wollte ich bei
AliExpress machen gerade
Ja, also
Wo war ich jetzt stehen geblieben?
Ich denke, das hat alles damit zu tun
wie viel Zeit man reinsteckt
und wie
fokussiert
und wie soll man das denn
zielstrebig man ist
und ich glaube, dass
gerade in asiatischen Ländern
diese Fokussiertheit
und Zielstrebigkeit
so dieses, der ganze Tag hier
wird gelernt
der ganze Tag wird Karrieregrind gemacht
und sowas, dass das dort einfach
mehr
gelebt wird
Ja und deswegen findest du da
wahrscheinlich auch so viele richtig
high IQ und so richtig
viele gute Leute
Auf der anderen Seite würde ich
sagen, findest du wahrscheinlich
in allen Bereichen
gute oder herausragende
Leute. Warum es statistisch
gesehen und das ist ja glaube ich gerade in den USA auch
so, dass Asiaten mit am besten
die besten Noten haben, die besten
Abschlüsse in den Unis und sowas
liegt es glaube ich echt so ein bisschen
an der Mentalität dahinter
dass da eben krass Leistung gebracht wird
fokussiert wird, sich fokussiert wird
und die auch wahrscheinlich übelst Ärger
kriegen daheim, wenn sie mal eine 2 geschrieben haben
und insofern
also nicht
die kommen nicht als Superentwickler auf die Welt
aber vielleicht haben sie einfach
mehr, soll man das nennen
Tatendrang
Disziplin, ja vielleicht
und sie bekommen sehr viel Druck von der
Familie, ja, das hört man auch
in einigen Videos, dass da richtig
die Kacke am Dampfen ist. Ich hab letztens ein Video geguckt
von einem, der hat erzählt
also er hat studiert in
Japan oder USA
ich bin mir gar nicht sicher
Nee, muss in den USA gewesen sein
oder es war jemand
der in den USA geboren ist, in Japan studiert
was auch immer, vollkommen
nee, Schwachsinn, muss in den USA
gewesen sein, Blödsinn, Blödsinn
sonst würde der Sinn, den ich jetzt erzählen will, überhaupt keinen Sinn
mehr ergeben, und zwar
ist in den USA am Studieren
und da hat er ein Video erzählt
so nach dem Motto, wenn es zu schlecht ist
haben ihm die Eltern gedroht, sie schicken ihn nach Japan
so, zur Oma, da muss er
da muss er quasi dann, dann wird er
die haben zu ihm gesagt so nach dem Motto, hier dann musst du
3 Jahre nach Japan zu Oma und Opa
wenn du nicht gut genug in der Uni bist
er hat halt
einen gewissen Antrieb dahinter, dass er sagt
ok, ich geb mir
Mühe, hab ich auch
schon von chinesischen Familien
also in Videos und Sachen
und Aussagen auf YouTube gehört, dass da wirklich
die Eltern richtig hart drauf sind, so nach dem Motto
ich schick dich zur Oma nach China zurück
die sind da hart drauf
glaube ich, also wie gesagt
ich denke nicht, dass die als super High IQ Entwickler
auf die Welt kommen, aber da ist
viel Arbeit, Disziplin und auch Druck von daheim
dahinter, dass du prozentual
da so viele gute Leute hast
hat sich
bis jetzt noch nicht ergeben, wir hatten
mal angefangen
dann hat er das Problem mit seinem Channel gehabt
und ja, dann
war eigentlich nichts mehr
dann haben wir das nicht mehr weiter verfolgt
Nice Max, Pog Erklärung
Command
C++ suckt
C++ kann man nicht anfangen
Guckst du eigentlich die anderen
Informatik YouTuber wie Chromik
Programmieren, Lernen, Niklas
also ab und zu
ab und zu gucke ich
von denen mal was
ähm
ich meine, ok
von ihm habe ich glaube ich
noch recht wenige Videos gesehen
ich weiß aber wen du meinst
der heißt glaube ich
Kevin
Chromik oder so
von dem habe ich ein Video letztens
geguckt, wo er Homeoffice gemacht hat
aus Spanien
und
das fand ich eigentlich ganz nice
und das war auch nicht so
ja ich sitze mit dem Laptop am Strand und
chille ab und alles ganz locker
und die anderen spielen Tischkicker, ne da hat er wirklich
auch was gearbeitet, das fand ich nicht schlecht
ansonsten habe ich von ihm relativ wenig Videos geguckt
Programmieren, Lernen, muss ich sagen
mir persönlich
sind die Inhalte von dem Video nicht so
dass die mir jetzt so viel
geben würden, ja
also das sind ja dann meistens solche Sachen wie
so lernst du jetzt
so lernst du jetzt besonders schnell
Javascript programmieren und die 5 Fehler
in den, weiß ich
interessiert mich jetzt persönlich nicht so sehr
ähm
vom Niklas
haben wir tatsächlich schon ein paar Videos geguckt
aber bei ihm bin ich immer
so die Frage, also er ist zweifelsfrei
auch äußerst ehrgeizig
und clever, sonst hätte er nicht
seinen super Uni Abschluss und sonst was
bei ihm bin ich, frage ich mich immer so
diese Videos, die sind
so ein Zwischending aus
so ein bisschen
Vibes von
Lifestyle Coaches
plus Marketing
Sellout und ein bisschen
IT
also muss ich sagen, gefallen mir jetzt auch
meistens nicht so
wobei wir das ein oder andere
geguckt haben, das war
eher nach meinem Geschmack, aber die meisten
Sachen sprechen mich nicht so an
gibt ja noch mehr, also
wen ich teilweise ganz
interessant finde, wobei ich sagen muss
da sind mir die Sachen schon oftmals
zu spezifisch
ist, also die Themen interessieren mich dann
oftmals einfach nicht so sehr
ist, äh, wie heißt der?
Morpheus, der macht teilweise
wirklich interessante Videos, wenn es halt ein
Thema ist, was mich interessiert, also ich meine ihn hier
den finde ich gut
allerdings muss ich sagen, manche Sachen sind auch
so spezifisch, das juckt mich jetzt
das zum Beispiel
juckt mich halt nicht, ja
wenn es aber mal ein Video gibt, was mich juckt
finde ich, macht er gute Videos
allerdings muss ich sagen, im deutschsprachigen
Bereich von
angenehm
wie angenehm das Ganze
vorgetragen wird, so wie die Videos
bearbeitet sind, so wie die
Themen aufbereitet sind, ich muss echt sagen
der Florian gefällt mir da mit Abstand
am besten, ja, ihn hier
da gucke ich tatsächlich öfters mal rein
wobei es halt auch so ist
dass mich die meisten Videos halt nicht großartig
interessieren, aber von
den deutschsprachigen IT-Channels
die ich kenne, gefällt er mir von den Videos
hier am besten. Spooky Musik
die beste Karriereentscheidung
meines Lebens, lass
mich raten, seinen Behördenjob zu kündigen
und, äh, Youtube und
ähm, tja, wie nennt man das?
Er ist ja glaube ich nicht wirklich
hauptberuflicher Youtuber, er macht ja so
ein Zwischending aus
ähm, Kursen und
und
Coaching, nee nicht Coaching
so Consulting Sachen und
Security
er macht ganz viele verschiedene Geschichten, aber wahrscheinlich dürfte
die beste Karriereentscheidung gewesen sein
dass er, er hat auch ein
Buch geschrieben zum Beispiel, dann wahrscheinlich wird
er in dem Video sagen, die beste Karriereentscheidung war
dass er seinen Behördenjob gekündigt hat
könnte ich mir vorstellen
und ich glaube ich hab das auch geguckt
vor einem Monat oder so, ich glaube das sagt er da auch
drin. In der Schule haben wir
Notepad++ verwendet
naja, wenn es sonst nichts besseres gibt, kann man sich das schon
geben
aber
ich bin der Meinung, es macht keinen Sinn
mehr Notepad++ zu benutzen, wenn man
auch einfach Visual Studio Code benutzen kann
was rundum einfach ein
sehr gelungener Editor ist
und vor allem durch die Erweiterbarkeit
für so gut wie alles verwendbar ist
Was ist an Behördenjobs so schlecht?
Oh, da musste mal
jemand fragen, der bei Behörden gearbeitet hat
also im Detail zumindest
ich kann dir sagen, die Bezahlung ist meistens nicht sonderlich gut
es ist sehr festgefahren, was du für
Aufstiegsmöglichkeiten hast
ich sag übrigens, ich muss erstmal mit Chat durchscrollen
bis wir bei der eigentlichen Frage sind
Recycle Story
Alter, ich komm wieder nicht hinterher
bin schon wieder 10 Minuten dran
ich muss mich mal beeilen
Naja, du erzählst auch keinem von deinem Youtube Account
Ich weiß nicht mal, auf was
sich das bezogen hat, aber
ich erzähle wenig, ja, darüber, das stimmt
Du wolltest
wollte ich? Ich wollte mal
wieder RGBs bestellen bei AliExpress, richtig?
RGB-LEDs
Wie denkst du, wird KI-Programmierer beeinflussen,
da Programmierer keine physische Arbeit ist?
Heute
obviously keine Gefahr
aber sagen wir in 5 Jahren, ist es auch keine Gefahr
Also, ich hab mich da
letztens im Stream relativ ausführlich
drüber ausgelassen, also ich denke schon
dass das Auswirkungen haben wird
Nicht nur auf Admins
generell auf IT-Berufe
allerdings
vergleiche ich das mal ein bisschen damit
mit diesen ganzen Low-Code-Plattformen
zumindest in einem Punkt
und zwar wurde da auch immer gesagt, bald braucht keiner mehr Programmierer
weil mit Low-Code-Plattformen
macht jetzt der Manager auf einmal Software
hat auch nicht funktioniert
und ich glaube auch nicht, dass wir erleben werden
dass KI auch in 5 Jahren
komplexe Software-Projekte
ganz allein umsetzt
Ich sehe KI eher
als Unterstützung für Programmierer
oder aber auch
wenn man jetzt aber wirklich mal ein bisschen nicht in 5 Jahren
ein bisschen, ein bisschen, vielleicht
10 Jahren guckt
dass im IT-Bereich
einiges mehr
was heute manuell gemacht wird
zumindest von KI
geplant wird und KI
vorschlägt, wie man das machen könnte
allerdings man dann immer noch Leute braucht
die das Ganze kontrollieren
und
überwachen
was da gemacht wird
also
ich denke schon, dass
das Einfluss halten wird, es hat ja jetzt schon Einfluss
auf das tägliche Arbeiten erhalten
sei es meine Datei rein zu
pasten und zu sagen, wo ist der Sündagsfehler
und sowas in der Richtung oder wo ist hier der Fehler
bringt oftmals schon was
dass das Programmierer überflüssig
machen wird, auf absehbare Zeit
glaube ich nicht
ich glaube auch nicht, dass es auf absehbare Zeit
Admins überflüssig machen wird
es wird wahrscheinlich die Arbeit
mehr ergänzen
und vielleicht
und wie gesagt, da reden wir jetzt aber denke ich
auch schon ein bisschen weiter als 5 Jahre
dass man
mehr Leute hat in so einer
also
Aufsichts- und Überprüfungsfunktion
um das zu bewerten, was KI
so vorschlägt, wenn das mal so gut ist
dass das auch auf
Ideen kommt, die so kein Mensch machen würde
Wir werden es erleben
Es ist immer sehr schwer, sowas zu prädikten
Nice
Und wie lief's?
Heute hatten noch 3 weitere
Ex-Kollegen von der alten Arbeit
hatten heute ihren ersten Arbeitstag
haben alle das gleiche gesagt wie ich
beim ersten Arbeitstag vor 3 Monaten
ist es komplett Informations-Overload
Jeder hat seine eigene Motivation
ja
Ist heute ein weeb-freundlicher Abend?
Chat ist heute
heute ist weebs in
oder?
Ich glaube heute ist weeb-freundlich
ja
denke schon
Wüsste ich jetzt nicht
Wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss
Ich glaube der einzige, der mir was sagt
ist der hier
und
das einzige Video
was ich von ihm im Hinterkopf habe
war sowas wie
Ich probiere zum ersten Mal C-Sharp aus
Taugt das was?
Wobei ich nicht sicher bin
ob das der war
Also
wie man daraus hört, gucke ich das auch nicht
Gibt es gute deutsche Channels
für Backend-Technologien?
Also ein
Channel, den ich tatsächlich wirklich gerne gucke
wenn es um aktuelle Themen
angeht, was
Frontend angeht und ein bisschen Backend
weil Node ist ja auch Backend
den hier
die gucke ich teilweise
wobei die, das ist ja nur einer
den gucke ich teilweise ganz gerne
allerdings auch nicht jedes Video
aber der hat wirklich gute Videos
wenn das halt, das ist wie bei mir
bei vielen Channels, wenn mich das Thema nicht interessiert
gucke ich es halt noch nicht
aber der hat wirklich gute Sachen, der hat zum Beispiel auch hier
mal letztens sein
Senf zu diesem Blog-Post von Microsoft
von Amazon
gegeben, so nach dem Motto
das sind Tote und sowas
deckt sich oftmals mit dem, was ich auch denke
und wie das so ist
ja oder hier, bloß keine
Meetings mehr, ich glaube da habe ich sogar
irgendwas drunter kommentiert
den finde ich ganz gut
Ok, also, was ist
an Behördenjobs so schlecht?
Also erstmal die Bezahlung
dass du sehr streng geregelte
Aufstiegsmöglichkeiten hast
so nach dem Motto, hast du nicht studiert
hast du Pech oder hier machst du mehr
was du sollst, gibt nicht mehr Geld, musst jetzt gefällig studieren
also ist ganz, ganz
weird champig
gibt es das Wort überhaupt
und, naja
ob so die Arbeit da einem zusagt
weiß ich halt nicht, das muss halt zu einem passen
das ist wahrscheinlich mehr, wir machen
halt
ja wir machen so Business as usual
wir machen halt so
nach Vorschrift
unsere Arbeit und alles was links und rechts ist
interessiert uns nicht
Freitag, 12 Uhr ist Schluss
ob das so ist, weiß ich nicht
ich weiß nicht
ich kann es dir aus Innenansicht
nicht berichten
war ich nie
in der IT bei Behörden
aber es geht nicht alles
mit der offenen Version
von Visual Studio Code, zum Beispiel
das offizielle C++ Plugin
geht nicht, weil die proprietäre
Binaries aus Visual Studio haben
und
die darf nur Microsoft distributen
Hallo
in diesem Stream nur ganz kurz
9 Euro Ticket
das können wir uns gleich mal angucken
Juniors werden immer weniger gebraucht mit KI
da Seniors mehr Arbeit mit KI machen können
ich glaube nichts
dass das dazu führt
also ehrlich gesagt, zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt
auf gar keinen Fall
also ich hab ChatGPT die einfachsten Dinger
gefragt und da kam Müll raus
wenn es ums Programmieren ging
also wohlgemerkt
wenn man
ChatGPT sagt, bau mir eine
Webseite mit einem Foto
von einer Katze drauf und so
das kriegt ChatGPT hin
aber zum Beispiel, so einfache Sachen wie
ähm
wie mach ich mit dem
Standard .NET
HTTP Client eine
CLI Progressbar
Fortschrittsleiste
oder Fortschrittsbalten
da hat ChatGPT
das haben wir sogar im Stream ausgeblendet
ChatGPT einfach kompletten Bullshit erzählt
mit Methoden die es nicht gibt
dann haben wir ChatGPT drauf hingewiesen
dass
das nicht stimmt
dass es diese Methoden überhaupt nicht gibt
und dann hat ChatGPT
einfach eine Windows Forms Anwendung generiert
mit irgendwelchen komischen
Progressbars
also das war echt nichts
ne ne
die haben nicht bei mir angefangen
die sind alle woanders hin
ich hab nur mit ihnen heute mich ausgetauscht
wie der erste Tag bei ihnen war
also zwei sind
ne sag ich jetzt nicht wohin, sind woanders hin
und einer ist noch woanders hin, die sind nicht bei mir
und die haben mehr oder weniger
das gleiche Gefühl gehabt als ich
angefangen hab, dort wo ich jetzt angefangen hab
und zwar dass es Informationsoverload ist
das was
das ist auch ein guter Punkt
oftmals Probleme macht
sind ja die sogenannten Edge Cases
wenn man Sachen entwickelt
also Dinger die zu 95%
funktionieren
das kriegt man ganz gut hin
aber dann alle Eventualitäten
auch noch mit zu bedenken
die so sein könnten, das wird dann schon ein bisschen
schwieriger, dazu kommt ganz gerne
dass Programmierer oder allgemein
egal ob es Programmierer sind oder
generell Mitarbeiter in einem Projekt
relativ schnell
sagen oh wir sind 80% fertig
und die letzten
20% dauern dann 80% der Zeit
ne
man kennts
wollte ich eben nicht noch
zu irgendwas etwas sagen
hab schon angefangen und hab gesagt ich beantworte es dann
wenn ich da bin
ok keine Ahnung mehr
mit den Behörden
ja das mit den Behörden war das
gell
glaube das mit den Behörden war das
ja gut Plattform I.O. geht nicht
wegen der C++ Extension
die nicht geht
Quantencomputer sind viel wichtiger
da gibt es ne lustige Geschichte von meiner aktuellen Arbeit
es gibt ein Projekt dort
wo securitytechnisch so gut wie
nichts schon bedacht ist
es dauert auch noch ne Weile bis das live geht
das einzige was sie aber bedacht haben ist
sie wollen sicher sein gegen Quantencomputerangriffe
ich hab mich zurückgehalten
ich hab auch gesagt mach dir mal
so nach dem Motto
1,2,3,4,5,6
als Passwort
aber hauptsache die Technologie wir dir untendrunter verwenden
ist sicher gegen Quantencomputerangriffe
ok nice wir haben es geschafft
ok also welche Stellen
was für ne Stellenanzeige soll ich mir jetzt angucken
Systemadministrator
gab es nicht noch eine die jemand unbedingt wollte
dass ich mir die angucke was da nicht funktioniert hat
Systemadministrator, MWD, Linux, Kassel, Partnerstandorte
Bochum, Koblenz
Homeoffice
Homeoffice ist schonmal gut dass das drinnen steht
direkt ne Übersicht
einfach mal ein Kommentar übersprungen
du musst mich teilweise schon erwähnen
ich seh das auch nicht im Chat alles
sonst komm ich ja gar nicht hinterher
ab sofort Follower Teilzeit
zwei gute Kombinationen Teilzeitmöglichkeit und Homeoffice
klingt schonmal nice
ich weiß halt nur wie sehr Homeoffice
möglich ist
kann auch sein
einmal die Woche darfst du daheim bleiben
was wen soll ich kugeln
ok
das ist ne gute Idee
der hat aber so nen Allerwelts
Namen
ne keine Ahnung
hab ich nicht gefunden
war aber ne gute Idee hätten wir ja mal probieren können
ok also lass mal kurz lesen
Spooky
Spooky Spooky Musik
alles klar
muss das mal kurz woanders
aufmachen das ist zu
ok du befindest dich hier
du bist der Garant für reibungslose IT Prozesse
im Gesamtunternehmen auch in kritischen Situationen
blablabla
damit dir dies gelingt
hast du aktuell technische Entwicklung
immer im Auge
was suchen die nochmal
nen Systemadministrator
treibst weiter Entwicklung voran
du brauchst im Zusammenspiel mit deinen Kollegen
die optimale Infrastruktur
für ein agiles Unternehmen
im Umfeld von Data Science und Big Data
huiuiui
dann bewirb dich bei
See Oda
E E ne ne
nicht See Oda E E Oda
Data Science und KI im Bereich Projekten
Obi
ist da nice
Respekt wer es selber macht
war das Obi
mit großer Passion
und kreativen Ansätzen tauche ich
also was wollen die haben
Administration der Linux
Infrastruktur, Client und
Server
ihr habt Linux Clients
das ist schon mal nicht schlecht
ich würde dort ein Linux Notebook kriegen
da wäre vielleicht auch was für mich
kein zu
kein verrammelte Windows Kiste mehr
ne
ich bin da eigentlich ganz happy wo ich jetzt gelandet bin
Administration unserer
Virtualisierungsplattform, Einrichtung von
Webservern und Datenbanken, Konfiguration
mit Ansible, das finde ich interessant
dass sie das
auch mal jetzt konkret reinschreiben was sie
da benutzen
Erste Ansprechpartner für Fragen von unseren
Kolleginnen
Erste Ansprechpartner für Fragen
ja ich meine
man weiß was sie damit sagen wollen
Überwachung und
Betrieb, ich würde nicht sagen
End-User-Support ist
das ist glaube ich nicht damit gemeint
es ist bloß unglücklich geschrieben
und wenn man es böse auslegt
genießt sich das wie End-User-Support
Überwachung und Betrieb der
Netzwerkinfrastruktur
Mitarbeiter in IT-Projekten
beziehungsweise
ok das ist
bis auf Ansible äußerst
Ansible und Linux äußerst
generic
du besitzt Erfahrung in der Administration einer
Infrastruktur
du verfügst über
eine heterogene
das haben sie auch gut umschrieben
du verfügst über
Kenntnisse in der Administration
also im Prinzip Wildwuchs auf gut Deutsch
ähm
du verfügst
oder heißt das überhaupt Wildwuchs in dem Fall
ja
schon oder
du verfügst über Kenntnisse in der
Administration einer
das heißt heterogen
wir müssen mal nachgucken
ungleich
du verfügst über
Proxmox
jeder der meinen letzten Proxmox
Stream gesehen hat kann einfach schon mal
reinschreiben in den Lebenslauf Proxmox
du konntest bereits erste
Erfahrungen mit Cloud-Anbietern sammeln
du beweist kreative
bla bla bla
bla bla
Bla bla bla
bla
Mitgestaltung einer dynamischen...
Okay, also man kann mitgestalten, wie sich das dynamisch entwickelt.
Pff, naja, okay, sowas in der Richtung schreiben viele.
Leidenschaft und Begeisterung.
Ach, das ist die Unternehmenskultur.
Flache Hierarchien, offene Türen und Kurzzeit.
Das schreiben auch gefühlt alle.
Ob es so ist, sieht man erst, wenn man dort ist.
Langfristig.
Vereinbarung von Homeoffice.
Sicherheit, betriebliche Altersvorsorge, Vermögens...
Gut, das machen viele mittlerweile.
Jobticket-Beitliese im Bahncard.
Jo, nice, warum nicht?
Diensthandy.
Auch nicht verkehrt.
Frisches Obst, Kaffee und kalte Getränke.
Zuzahlung zur Internet- und Lunch-Corporate-Payments.
Ähm...
Ist...
Ist durchaus okay.
Also...
Ich mein, man könnte die Stellenanzeige sicherlich noch ansprechender schreiben.
Man könnte die Stellenanzeige sicherlich noch ansprechender schreiben.
Gerade die, was sie eigentlich wollen, ist sehr 0815.
Man weiß nicht genau.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen, wenn das bei dir in der Nähe ist und du darüber nachdenkst, dich dazu zu bewerben, warum nicht?
Bzw. ich glaube, jemand, der die Stellenanzeige gepostet hat, meinte sogar, er hat dort ein Vorstellungsgespräch.
Morgen oder so.
Leute, ich hab zu viele Tabs auf.
Ich muss mal Tabs schließen.
Es ist zu viel. Es sind zu viele Tabs.
Es sind zu viele...
Firmen wie Google...
Okay.
Ach, da haben wir ihn doch. Hat vorhin jemand gefragt.
Es ist zu viel.
Zu viel auf.
Langsam erkenne ich die Tabs nicht mehr, was was ist.
100% Homeoffice.
Okay, das ist nice.
Hatten wir das nicht gestern erst?
Nee, hatten wir nicht.
Ist was anderes.
Okay, letzte Stellenanzeige, die wir heute angucken.
Also, let's go.
Systemadministrator for MWare.
Oh, da hab ich keine Ahnung von.
Können wir das Video schauen?
Welches?
Probearbeiten bald.
Ja, bin mal gespannt, was du berichtest.
Lesezeichen?
Nee.
Lesezeichen sind outdated, overrated, jebaited.
So was benutze ich nicht.
Ctrl-Shift-A, das kenne ich.
Ich weiß auch, dass man mehrere Sachen anklicken kann.
Aber die Frage ist nur, was mache ich dann mit den Tabs?
Äh, okay, weiß ich nicht.
Also, lass mal gucken.
Oh, Edif.
Ach, das sind die.
Deswegen kam das mir bekannt vor.
Von denen haben wir schon mal was gesehen.
Der Schwerpunkt liegt dabei auf vor allem von Microsoft und SAP-Technologien.
Oh Gott!
Das ist ja eine Kombination, da hätte ich richtig Bock drauf.
Okay, aber in dem Fall suchen sie ja jemanden für VMware.
Okay, bla bla bla bla.
Muss man sich nicht angucken.
Das sind deine Aufgaben.
Als Teil eines dynamischen...
Okay.
Es setzt bei mir direkt der Resident-Sleeper-Reflex ein, wenn ich den ersten Satz schon lese.
Als Teil eines dynamischen Teams installierst du...
Direkt eingeschlafen.
Instant-Tiefschlaf.
Okay.
Ich muss mir jetzt die Augen aufhalten, Leute.
Als Teil eines dynamischen Teams installierst du, wartest du und betreust du die hochverfügbare virtuelle Infrastruktur.
VMware vSphere, VMware ESX.
Okay.
Leute, ich habe keine Ahnung von VMware.
Muss ich jetzt mal gestehen.
Ich weiß bis heute nicht den Unterschied zwischen VMware ESX und VMware vSphere.
Ich glaube, VMware ESX ist die eigentliche Virtualisierungsplattform.
Und vSphere ist so ein bisschen das UI und HA-Geschichten drumherum.
Aber nicht sicher und keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt.
Also, weiß das jemand von euch?
Ihr seid doch so schlau, Chat.
Was ist der Unterschied dazwischen?
Übrigens, an der Stelle muss ich mal darauf hinweisen, weil Anfang des Monats ist.
Viele von euch haben sicherlich noch ihren Prime-Sub offen.
Und wenn ihr den Prime-Sub offen habt, dann wäre es sehr sinnvoll, den auf Twitch zu verteilen.
Wenn auch nicht an mich, dann an irgendjemand auf Twitch.
Gerade kleine Streamer freuen sich da sehr drüber.
Und mit kleinen Streamern meine ich jetzt nicht unbedingt mich.
Sondern Leute mit 5 Zuschauern.
Wenn ihr da jemanden habt, den ihr gerne guckt, der sich vielleicht überlegt, soll ich das weitermachen?
Vielleicht höre ich auf zu streamen.
Sobald ihr den Prime-Sub gebt, flippen die aus.
Habe ich schon selbst erlebt.
Ich habe mal einen 5-Viewer-Streamer einen Prime-Sub gegeben.
Das ist komplett eskaliert.
Aber ihr könnt ihn natürlich auch gerne mir geben.
Ich will mich jetzt nicht aufträngen, ja?
Yoko auch wieder am Start.
POG-Subscription. Nice.
Danke für den Sub.
RoadKick. POG-Subscription. Danke schön, Leute.
Und Murksa auch wieder am Start.
Zum Glück nicht beim Mixer hängen geblieben.
POG-Subscription. Nice. Danke schön, Leute.
V-Center Clusters ESX. Okay, ich dachte, das kann ESX selbst.
Okay, let's go. Ich muss mich da jetzt durchquälen.
Also. Weiter geht's.
Also. Du hast...
Du verantwortest... Okay, das ist...
Du verantwortest die Installation in Betriebnahme von komplexen Serversystemen.
Die Installation in Betriebnahme.
Meinen die damit, ich gehe ins Rechenzentrum?
Oder meinen die damit, ich richte die Initial ein?
Auch so Sachen wie Management Interface und sowas?
Oder ist das einfach nur eine Floskel? Man weiß es ja nicht.
Du hast das Monitoring HP...
Oh, please. Please.
Ich habe es nie benutzen müssen.
Aber ich kenne Erzählungen davon.
Oder nicht, dass ich das...
Vielleicht bringe ich es auch durcheinander.
Aber ich kenne Erzählungen von und Screenshots davon.
Und das ist ganz, ganz...
Ja, das ist Open View. Alter.
Das muss, glaube ich, so ziemlich das Schlimmste sein, was es gibt in der Richtung.
Okay, One View ist die neue Variante davon anscheinend.
Okay, das ist...
Zugegeben, das ist eine ganz, ganz alte Version, die man sieht.
Das sieht neuerdings auch nicht viel besser aus.
One View ist anscheinend die neue Version davon, die jetzt moderner aussieht.
Was ein Schrott, Alter.
Okay, One View ist anscheinend gar nicht mehr so old school und sieht nicht so outdated aus.
Geocode, ich glaube, es ist tatsächlich eher für reines Hardware-Monitoring von HP-Servern.
Aber ich war mir nicht sicher.
Ich habe es ja selbst nie verwendet.
Okay, V-Realize Operations, V-Realize Loginsight.
Kenne ich auch nicht.
Und die Optimierung der Umgebung im Blick.
Okay.
Als Expertin für VMware übernimmst du die Kundenberatung und begleitest Werkstatt-Arbeit mit unserer Fachabteilung zusammen.
Die Kundenberatung?
Ich denke, du sollst dich um ihre Infrastruktur kümmern.
Welche Kunden sollst du da beraten?
Oder sind das so welche, die sagen so, wir sind das Team VMware-Virtualisierung,
unsere Kunden sind Linux-Administration, Anwendungsentwicklung,
die quasi intern auch immer so nice von Kunden sprechen, weil das sich in BWL ausgedacht hat.
Das sind bestimmt solche.
Ja, dann ist das ziemlich 0815.
Hast du eigentlich auch Ahnung von Oracle-Dingen?
Ja, ich weiß, dass die Lizenzierung komplett für den Arsch ist.
Das reicht, was man über Oracle wissen muss.
Und im Arsch meine ich richtig im Arsch.
Ich erzähle dir jetzt mal zwei Sachen über Oracle-Lizenzierung.
So, das Erste ist, das ist alles schon nicht mehr so aktuell.
Also nicht mehr so aktuell.
Also nicht mehr neu, wo ich das mitbekommen habe.
Es kann sein, dass es anders ist, wohlgemerkt.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es anders ist.
Also, das Erste ist, wenn ihr eine Oracle-Datenbank auf einer VM betreiben wollt,
dann bezahlt ihr Lizenzkosten nicht dafür, wie viele Kerne ihr wirklich benutzt,
sondern wie viele Kerne der Host hat.
Also, habt ihr eine Virtualisierungsinfrastruktur-Hardware,
sagen wir mit 32 Kernen, richtig viel RAM und alles unten drunter,
ihr betreibt aber darauf eine VM, die nur zwei CPU-Cores hat und Oracle drauf,
dann bezahlt ihr für 32 Kerne die Lizenz, nicht für zwei.
Oracle-Lizenzierung.
Auch schon sehr nice.
Außer, okay, ich gebe zu, die Story habe ich wahrscheinlich schon öfters erzählt,
weil der Chat das weiß.
Oder Strohflip, weißt du das?
Oder ist das, weil ich das schon fünfmal erzählt habe?
Außer, und das ist das, wie Oracle versucht, wieder die Leute dazu zu bringen,
einen Chit zu kaufen, den sonst keiner haben will.
Außer, ihr benutzt die Oracle-Virtualisierungslösung,
die ROTS ist, im Vergleich zu VMWare.
Aber dort drauf bezahlt ihr nur die in der VM benutzten Kerne.
Könnt ihr das kontrollieren? Ja, bei irgendwelchen Kontrollen schon,
so Remote nicht.
Wo wir aber schon wieder beim zweiten Punkt sind.
Ach ja, man hätte übrigens, bevor ich das sage,
man hätte natürlich auch extra für die Datenbank einen schmalbrüstigeren Cluster
bauen können mit ESX oder Nodes.
Ja, aber das ist halt eklig.
So, wäre da nicht das zweite Problem bei Oracle-Lizenzen?
Und zwar, wenn du jetzt auf die Idee kommst,
ach, naja, da lizenzieren wir mal unsere Datenbank ordentlich,
aber wir können ja bei einem Betriebssystem für unsere Server
weiterhin Oracle-Linux benutzen, was man kostenlos verwenden darf.
Dann sagt Oracle, wie, ihr wollt Oracle-Linux kostenlos verwenden?
Ja gut, ja gut, das gibt es zwar kostenlos,
aber nicht, wenn ihr schon was anderes bei uns lizenziert habt.
Wenn du nämlich eine Sache bei Oracle lizenziert hast,
dann bist du verpflichtet, alles andere, was du von Oracle kaufst,
mindestens auf dem Niveau zu lizenzieren, wie das, was du schon hast.
Also, du hast eine Datenbank auf was weiß ich Gold-Level zertifiziert,
fragt mich nicht, ob es da sowas gibt, ich kenn mich damit nicht aus,
und du möchtest allerdings 500 Linux-Hosts betreiben mit Oracle,
Unbreakable Linux nennt sich das Ganze übrigens,
dann sagen die zu dir, nee, hättest du keine Datenbank von uns,
dann könntest du 500 Installationen Oracle-Linux kostenlos benutzen,
du hast aber eine Datenbank bei uns.
Das heißt, du musst diese 500 Installationen Oracle-Linux
auch mindestens mit dem Standard lizenzieren,
wie du unsere Datenbank lizenziert hast.
Oracle ist einfach Schrott und sollte an jeder Stelle vermieden werden,
wo es sich nur vermeiden lässt.
Absoluter Bullshit, der Laden, Alter.
Okay, und wohlgemerkt, Disclaimer, bevor mich jetzt Oracle verklagt oder so,
ich weiß nicht, ob das noch aktuell ist,
geht davon aus, dass es alles nicht stimmt, was ich erzählt habe, okay?
Ach ja, du hast recht, es geht um Support, es geht um Support.
Ja, richtig, wenn du Support nicht, das ist richtig,
es geht nicht um die eigentliche Lizenz, es betreiben zu dürfen,
es geht um den Support-Level, den du dir gekauft hast, das meine ich ja.
Ja, das, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte.
Es geht um den Support-Level, also wenn du die Support-Sache gekauft hast,
für ein Oracle-Produkt musst du alle anderen auch damit lizenzieren,
was im Zweifelsfall Millionen kosten kann.
Aber ist Microsoft so viel besser?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Aber ich glaube, so schlimm wie Oracle sind nicht viele.
Raspberry Pi-Rechenzentrum.
Oder es ist noch schlimmer.
Wie gesagt, ich glaube, es sollte jetzt, allein schon,
weil ich erzählt habe, sollte jeden abschrecken, sich den Mist zu kaufen.
Es ist wirklich so, ohne Scheiß, einfach nicht Oracle benutzen.
Das ist das Wildeste, was ich je gesehen habe, okay?
Con...
Cosalux.
Machen wir das mal hier auf.
Wir gucken jetzt erst mal die Stellenanzeige fertig.
Das war dann wirklich die letzte heute.
Ähm, ja.
Und wer jetzt gelacht hat und denkt,
die können doch unmöglich ihr Linux Unbreakable nennen, doch.
Das heißt so und es hat sogar so ein komisches Logo.
Hahaha.
Ups.
Falscher Button, das war ich.
Also dazu weiß ich echt nicht mehr, was ich sagen soll.
Aber damit macht man Big Stunks bei Oracle.
Also nicht unbedingt mit Oracle Linux,
sondern mit ihrem Lizenzierungsmodell und Support-Modell.
Das ist fast schon eine Stufe vor...
Wahrscheinlich arbeitet Carlos Matos von New York City mittlerweile auch bei Oracle.
Okay, also.
Ich wollte jetzt erst mal den Kram hier fertig lesen.
Ähm, Gollum xxxxx, ich muss das gleich lesen.
Ich muss jetzt, sonst komme ich mit dem Chat echt nicht hinterher.
Markiere mir das mal, dass ich das gleich wieder finde.
Okay, das ist... geht alles klar.
Du bearbeitest Anfragen und Störungsmeldungen,
übernimmst deren Dokumentation im Ticketsystem,
incident, problem und change...
Okay, nimmst dann den Ruf...
Kann sich lohnen von der Kohle her.
Ist die Frage, wie demanding das Ganze ist, ja?
Wie oft gibt es da Anrufe?
Wie sind die Sachen so eingeteilt und so?
Ja.
Das bringst du mit.
Du verfügst über ein abgeschlossenes Studium oder Wirtschafts...
Okay, bla bla bla bla.
Im Rahmen einer mehrjährigen Praxis erfahrst du umfassende Kenntnisse im Bereich virtuelle Umgebung,
vor allem bei WSphere.
So wie im Bereich der...
Das haben sie da oben schon mal geschrieben.
x86 Hardware Cisco UCS.
Ist das Unified Communication oder was ist das?
Nee, nee.
Cisco...
Unified Computing System, so.
Del... HP Del Lenovo.
Wen...
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, ja?
Wen juckt es, von welchem Hersteller die Servers sind?
Aber...
Das sind ja...
Das hat ja mit den Server...
Der Hersteller der Hardware hat doch nichts mit der Umgebung an sich zu tun.
Aber okay.
Lassen wir das mal durchgehen.
Du hast bereits Kenntnisse im Netzwerkumfeld,
im Saal- und Storage-Bereich,
sowie erste Bürgerungspunkte für MWare.
Kenntnisse im Bereich der Automatisierung,
zum Beispiel Ansible.
Scripting, zum Beispiel PowerShell.
Java...
Javascript?
Okay, ich glaube Javascript braucht man in dem Bereich tatsächlich sehr selten.
Jason Rest.
Einfach mal...
Einfach mal random vier Begriffe hingeschrieben,
die so gut wie nichts miteinander zu tun haben.
Aber okay.
Unterstreichen in deinem Profil.
Du konntest bereits erfahren im Bereich Backup und Restore VM.
Okay.
Ja.
Auch wenn ich das jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen mies gemacht habe,
liest sich eigentlich ziemlich 0815.
Jetzt nicht so, dass ich vor Freude im Dreieck springen würde,
wenn ich da hin könnte
zum Vorstellungsgespräch.
Beziehungsweise die Begeisterung wird schon Grenzen halten, glaube ich.
Rein von der Anzeige
kann natürlich trotzdem ein guter Laden sein.
Das ist immer nicht wirklich so repräsentativ.
Es ist halt das, was wir bewerten können
Eindruck für den Bewerber, so eine Stellenanzeige. Genauso wie das umgedreht ja auch der Fall ist.
Deswegen fände ich es cool, wenn sie es irgendwann mal auf die Reihe kriegen würden,
ein bisschen weniger Resident-Sleeper-Stellenanzeigen zu schreiben, alle.
Okay, Homeoffice steht nicht drin, aber es steht mobiles Arbeiten drin,
was ja quasi ein super Set von Homeoffice ist. Mal ein paar schlaue Begriffe einstreuen hier
nebenbei. Vielfältige Karriere- und Weiterbildungsmöglichkeiten, blablabla.
Attraktives Behaltsgehaltspaket, wenn das doch so attraktiv ist, schreibt doch einfach
mal eine Hausnummer hin, dann bewerben sich vielleicht auch Leute.
Eine moderne und innovative Arbeitsumgebung, ein eigenes...
Das ist tatsächlich, das ist tatsächlich wirklich ein guter Vorteil, ja.
Subventionierte Kantine und kostenlose Parkplätze, wenn man nochmal hin muss,
das finde ich nicht schlecht. Gut, dass man das auch hervorhebt.
Eine ökonomische Arbeitsplätze, ein hochmoderner...
Kostenlose Getränke, frisches Obst. Warum zum Teufel schreiben die alle frisches Obst rein?
Wen juckt frisches Obst? Okay, ja, ganz, ganz okay, würde ich sagen, ja.
Halt sehr super business generic geschrieben hier auch, aber wenn das das ist, wo deine Skills
liegen und dich das anspricht, weil es vielleicht bei dir um die Ecke ist, wer auch immer das gepostet
hat, warum nicht? Wie gesagt, das muss nicht repräsentativ sein, so wirklich für das
Unternehmen, wie es denn dann da ist, zu arbeiten. Das ist halt der erste Eindruck, den man hat.
So, Chetke. Also, wo gab's denn? Hier gab's eine super lange Frage im Chat.
Hi Max, mal eine Frage. Ich bin gerade mit der... Leute, übrigens, ich muss jetzt mal eine Sache
noch allgemein zum Stream sagen. Ich weiß, wir haben in letzter Zeit wenig Bastelsachen gemacht,
aber ich stehe halt immer, ich muss das jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen erklären, ich stehe
halt immer vor der Auswahl abends, wenn ich übelst im Arsch bin oder gerade auch unter der Woche,
wenn ich arbeiten war. Entweder mache ich einfach gar keinen Stream und chill ein bisschen ab und
gucke Amazon, YouTube, sonst was, nehme vielleicht für YouTube noch was auf,
mache ein Spiel, ein paar Sachen oder ich mache den Stream an. Dann habe ich aber null vorbereitet
und habe meistens auch keinen großartigen Bock, mir komplett neue Sachen anzugucken. Das heißt,
da ist dann bloß die Auswahl zwischen, wir machen ein bisschen Laber und links und rechts
paar Sachen angucken, Stream oder gar keinen Stream und ich denke einfach mal, dass es den
meisten Leute lieber ist oder die es präferieren, dass es einen Stream gibt versus es gibt keinen
Stream. Aber es wird auch wieder die Zeit kommen, das kann ich euch versprechen, dass wir Bastelsachen
machen und das muss ich einfach alles noch ein bisschen einpendeln und ich brauche mal wieder ein
paar Bastelprojekte, wo ich richtig Bock drauf habe. Es gab ja immer mal so Phasen, wo wir mal
ein bisschen mehr, mal ein bisschen weniger programmiert haben, ein bisschen mehr, mal ein
bisschen weniger gebastelt haben. Im Zweifelsfall, wer sowas gucken will, im Archiv gibt es jede
Menge Bastelstreams und wir haben ja schon alles mehr oder weniger mal zumindest gestreift vom
Thema her. Und ich habe eine ganz lange Liste mit Sachen, die ich mir angucken will. Zick. Soll ich
das wirklich machen? KQ. Nee, Okammel bestimmt nicht. Okay, also jetzt lesen wir mal die Frage.
Von Gollum XXXXXX. Da fehlt bloß noch 360 HD Quickscope oder sowas dahinter. Okay, Hi Max,
mal eine Frage. Ich bin gerade mit meiner Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker Systemintegration
fertig geworden und möchte gerne beruflich mich in Richtung Linux admin. Was hast du denn in der
Ausbildung so gemacht? Weiterentwickeln? Bei mir auf der Arbeit ist das leider nicht möglich.
Beschäftige mich privat aktuell viel damit, um mir die Sachen selbst beizubringen. Hast du Tipps?
Eventuell, wie ich mit deiner Erfahrung, wie ich mich da am besten weiterentwickle, um beruflich
voranzukommen? Wissen auch von das Beruf? Ja, also gerade im Linux Bereich gibt es ja sehr viel, was
man sich angucken kann. Also das fängt an von, ich kaufe mal einen Raspberry Pi, wobei das würde
ich aktuell nicht erzählen. Ich kaufe mal einen Raspberry Pi und beschäftige mich ein bisschen
generell mit Linux. Ich installiere mir Linux in AVM, probiere ein bisschen aus. Also das Beste,
was du machen kannst, wenn du so ein Gefühl für Linux bekommen willst, dann mach das, was ich hier
auch gemacht habe. Installiere Linux in AVM neben deinem Windows. Also das hier läuft in AVM.
Installiere das neben deinem Windows und arbeite deine tägliche Arbeit in der AVM dort, wo es passt.
Also wenn du Sachen spielen willst, mach das unter Windows. Aber beschäftige dich damit, administriere
Sachen von Linux aus, programmiere Sachen von Linux aus, gucke im Internet rum von Linux aus, skripte
Sachen von Linux aus, mach Analyse von irgendwelchen Sachen von Linux aus. Arbeite tagtäglich mit Linux.
Und man denkt sich so, ja gut, aber was hat das mit Linux Servern zu tun? Ja, ziemlich viel, weil
Kommandozeilenbedienung ist auf Linux Servern das gleiche wie bei Linux lokal. Du hast vielleicht ein paar
Tools mehr installiert bei dir lokal, als du auf dem Server hast. Aber wenn du dich ordentlich auf einer
Linux-Shell bewegen kannst, ist das das A und O für einen fertigen Server-Admin-Physi im Linux-Bereich.
Das ist das Wichtige. Du musst dich per SSH und dann mit der Shell auf dem Linux-System ordentlich
bewegen können. Und nachdem du ja nicht täglich daheim bei dir irgendwelche großartigen Linux-
Administrationstasks hast, ist tägliches Benutzen davon einfach das Beste, was du machen kannst.
Du kannst dir auch, wenn du ein bisschen advancere Sachen willst, du kannst dir beispielsweise auch
wie ich hier einen Arch-Linux installieren und selbst alles mal von Hand einrichten. Desktop, Terminal,
ordentliche Shell, deinen Prompts, machst ein Wim-Config und guckst dir das alles mal mit der Zeit an.
Also durch das Customizen von deinem System und das tägliche Benutzen von deinem Linux-System
lernst du enorm viel. Und das ist auch was, was dir beim Administrieren von Servern was bringt.
Oder generell beim Administrieren von Linux-Systemen. Du musst dich erstmal mit Linux ein bisschen auskennen.
Du musst wissen, wo liegen irgendwelche Programme, wann guckt man unter Warlock irgendwas und so Dinger.
Wie gucke ich mir Boot-Lock-Messages an, wie starte ich Dienste, wie sorge ich dafür, dass die automatisch
gestartet werden, solche Geschichten. Wie gucke ich nach, wie voll die Festplatte ist, welche Dienste hängen.
Es gibt einen weiteren Tipp, den ich dir geben kann. Wenn du dich dann ein bisschen damit beschäftigt hast,
also ein bisschen die Grundlagen von Linux angeguckt hast, dann versuch dich hier ran.
Das ist die einzige Seite dieser Art, die ich kenne und das ist eine wirklich, ich lass mal kurz Darkseam an,
das ist eine wirklich super Geschichte, um seine Linux-Skills zu testen und zu üben.
Das ist ein bisschen was in der Richtung, wie man kennt von Programmier-Challenges und Security-Challenges.
So zum Beispiel Versuche rauszubekommen, wie man sich auf dieser Webseite einloggen kann.
Oder dieses und dieses Problem muss gelöst werden, wer programmiert am schnellsten was.
Das ist quasi sowas für Linux-Admins. Das sind insgesamt 20 Challenges von leicht bis schwer.
Und manche davon sind wirklich nicht easy auf den ersten Blick.
Also bei den ein oder anderen habe ich auch ein bisschen überlegen müssen.
Wir haben die alle hier im Stream gemacht und ich mache das schon eine ganze Weile.
So und wenn du das hier durch hast, dann bist du wirklich ziemlich fit, was das angeht.
Also wenn du das alles hinbekommst, dann bist du am Ende relativ fit in Linux.
Also das ist quasi der Beweis dafür, dass du was gelernt hast.
Ein weiterer Tipp, den ich dir geben kann. Linux alleine ist nur die halbe Miete.
Man muss sich auch ein bisschen mit so dem ganzen Ökosystem beschäftigen und allem drum herum.
Zum Beispiel Linux selbst läuft ja nicht isoliert irgendwo.
Cloud-Umgebung und quasi als Server-Admin werden Cloud-Umgebung immer wichtiger.
Pick dir eine raus, neben Azure, neben Google Cloud, neben AWS, ist eigentlich egal.
Ich persönlich finde zum Einstieg AWS am angenehmsten, aber da kann man sich sicherlich lang drüber streiten.
Und beschäftige dich ein bisschen mit Cloud-Technologien.
So wie legt man da VMs an?
Irgendwann, wenn du dich da gut auskennst, kannst du da auch mal so einen Blick auf Containerisierung werfen.
Vielleicht dann auch irgendwann mal, wie man sich ein Kubernetes-Cluster anguckt.
Ein Kubernetes-Cluster-Administrator. Das sind schon sehr, sehr advanced Topics jetzt.
Aber man geht halt immer weiter.
Aber ich glaube zum Einstieg ist das mit der VM das Beste.
Und dann kannst du dich natürlich irgendwo bewerben.
Ich meine, ganz ehrlich, du hast eine Physi-Ausbildung abgeschlossen.
Du schreibst in deinen Lebenslauf.
Und bei deinen Skills schreibst du schon deine Linux-Sachen hin.
Übrigens, auch als Physi finde ich es nicht schlecht, wenn man einen GitHub-Account hat.
Gar nicht so sehr für irgendwelche Frontend-Javascript-To-Do-Listen, Fake-Projekte oder sowas.
Aber ein GitHub-Account macht immer einen guten Eindruck.
Und du kannst in deinem GitHub-Account ja auch Sachen hinterlegen,
die dich als fähigen Admin ausweisen.
Zum Beispiel kannst du Skripte hochladen.
Du kannst Ansible-Playbooks hochladen.
Oder sowas in der Richtung.
Ja, mit Server-Automatisierung generell, was Ansible angeht,
Terraform und sowas, muss man sich früher oder später auch mal beschäftigen.
Aber ich würde sagen, wenn du erstmal nur reinkommen willst,
installiere dir eine Linux-VM, beschäftige dich richtig, customise die.
Vor allem deine Shell-Umgebung, da lernst du schon sehr viel dabei.
Von welcher Shell benutze ich, wie konfiguriere ich meinen Vim,
wie komme ich aus Vim erstmal überhaupt wieder raus.
Und dann kannst du dir das ja auch langsam angucken.
Aber nicht frustriert sein, dass du vielleicht über Easy erstmal nicht rauskommst,
das ist nicht schlimm.
Du wirst mit der Zeit sehen, wenn du besser wirst, du kannst die nach und nach alle lösen.
Also wir haben im Stream alle durchgemacht.
Ich glaube, das Einzige, wo ich die Zeit einmal gerissen habe,
weil ich komplett in die falsche Richtung geguckt habe, war...
Weiß ich gar nicht mehr, was war denn das?
Das Database-Ding, glaube ich, gell?
Ich glaube, das mit der Datenbank.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Suche Physi-Ausbildung, please.
Okay, Leute.
Jemand hier im Stream der Ambulance direkt einstellt?
Also das ist, glaube ich, als Bewerbung schon mehr als ausreichend.
Suche Physi-Ausbildung, please.
Kannst du mal darauf reagieren? Was ist das für ein Video?
Das ist doch ein April-Scherz, oder?
Ja, das ist...
Das ist ein...
Ja, ja.
Voicelabs, das ist irgendein G-Bated-Video.
Okay, vielleicht, ja.
Das ist...
Ist das alles AI-generiert?
Aber über meinen Klo geht eh nix. Bestes Klo überhaupt.
Fabian schreibt, wo ich jetzt arbeite, gibt es eine Kantine und bis zu vier Gerichte am Tag für 40 Cent pro Patient.
Also bei mir in der Kantine, also bei mir auf der Arbeit, ist das wirklich sehr, sehr angenehm.
Und zwar...
Man bezahlt...
Also ich habe letztens...
Ich sage euch mal, was ich gegessen habe, ja?
Ich habe letztens eine Hauptspeise gegessen, das war...
Ich glaube...
In dem Fall Spaghetti mit...
Spaghetti Bolognese.
Richtig ordentlicher Teller voll.
Nudeln mit Lachs.
Genau.
Spaghetti Bolognese.
Richtig cooler Teller voll.
Einen vollgepackten Salat.
Nachtisch.
Und was zu trinken.
Also, danach war ich wirklich vollgefressen, Alter.
Das habe ich...
Wie hat meine Oma gesagt? Die Augen waren größer als der Magen.
Zumindest, was habe ich bezahlt am Ende? 6,30 Euro.
Also so eine subventionierte Kantine ist schon enorm Porc.
In Wirklichkeit, in Wirklich...
Also, was heißt in Wirklichkeit? Das war ja wirklich.
Also, in irgendeinem Laden nicht subventioniert, hätte ich da wahrscheinlich 25 Euro für gelatzt.
Du schaust keinen Stream außer Max, so muss das sein.
Porc.
Ne, das würde ich nicht machen. Ich würde Linux in einer VM installieren.
Wie genau läuft das bei dir eigentlich mit deinem Linux unter Windows?
Hast du das einfach in einer VM laufen?
Korrekt, guck da.
VM.
Man sieht sogar noch hier, wenn ich rausgehe, dass es eine VM ist.
Aber das, was ich in Linux mache, ist halt so, dass es performance-technisch in einer VM ruhig richtig gut läuft.
Ich meine, CPU-Performance ist eh kein großer Unterschied zwischen Native und VM.
GPU sieht das Ganze wieder anders aus, aber ich mache hier nichts, was krass GPU-Features bräuchte.
Die Sachen, die in einer VM gehen, sind allerdings durchaus performance-technisch in Ordnung.
Ja, also, äh, hab ich's doch installiert.
Wie heißt denn das Ding?
Heaven? Ne.
Heaven? Alter, ich kann das mal richtig suchen.
Heaven.
Gott, ich bin so pp-ga.
Heaven. Ne.
Heaven? Bench?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie der Scheiß heißt.
Ach so, einfach so.
Naja.
Also man sieht, wenn man hier einblendet, FPS-Anzeige und so.
Das läuft in einer VM und das läuft auch ganz brauchbar in einer VM.
Guck hier.
100, 180 FPS.
Quality.
Ultra.
Ultra-Settings.
Auf Low geht's wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen mehr.
Guck, auf Low haben wir 244.
Also das geht schon ganz, ganz brauchbar.
In einer VM.
Das Problem in der VM ist ehrlich gesagt nicht so sehr, dass die Sache wahnsinnig unperformant GPU-technisch laufen würde.
Die Sache ist die, das ist halt nur eine virtuelle GPU.
Da wird nix durchgereicht.
Bei der CPU, die CPU ist witzigerweise das einzige, was eigentlich gar nicht so richtig virtualisiert ist in einer VM.
Und die Features, die da unterstützt werden, sind halt mickrig im Vergleich zu einer echten GPU.
Das, was unterstützt wird, läuft halbwegs performant.
Aber nachdem man in einer VM hier, zumindest ich, eigentlich nahezu nix macht, was GPU-Performance und Features bräuchte.
Ist jetzt nicht so, als würde ich da Blender benutzen.
Kann ich das für nahezu alles benutzen, was ich tagsüber so mache.
Meine Linux-VM.
Ja, GPU-Videodecoding fehlt halt für 4K-Videos zum Beispiel.
Magst du lieber Linux als VM auf Windows laufen lassen oder Dualboot?
Es kommt ein bisschen drauf an.
So, was du alles benutzt.
Ich persönlich finde dieses Setup am besten, weil man kann beide Systeme parallel benutzen.
Ich mache alles unter Linux, was sich unter Linux anbietet.
Zum Beispiel eine Runde Entspannen mit Asciiquarium oder auch das Ganze in Cup of Pride.
Also, wenn ich irgendwas programmieren will, mache ich das unter Linux.
Wenn ich netzwerktechnisch irgendwas gucken will, mache ich das unter Linux.
Wenn ich irgendwas an neuer Software ausprobieren will, also irgendwas Open-Source-Technik, mache ich es natürlich unter Linux.
Wenn ich im Internet was gucken will, gerade wenn ich irgendwo unterwegs bin, wo ich nicht genau weiß, was die Seiten so treiben oder Sachen holen, mache ich das unter Linux.
Wenn ich irgendwas debuggen muss, mache ich das unter Linux. Ich mache quasi alles unter Linux, was man gut unter Linux machen kann.
Für den Rest streamen, Videos editieren, Sachen spielen, Thumbnails erstellen für Videos, das mache ich unter Windows.
Ich nehme einfach das, was sich für den jeweiligen Task am besten eignet, fertig.
Deswegen finde ich auch, dass es enorm viele Möglichkeiten gibt, eine VM neben Windows laufen zu haben, also eine Linux-VM neben Windows laufen zu haben.
Es gibt mittlerweile die Möglichkeit, mit WSL 2 auch vieles davon zu machen.
Ich mag meine VM auf dem zweiten Desktop allerdings trotzdem lieber, weil ich da auch ein vollständiges i3 laufen lassen kann.
Einfach so ein Fullscreen-Linux ist für mich immer noch das Beste.
WSL 2 ist noch Mist deiner Meinung nach, sagt Sebasu-Chan. Warum?
Also interessiert mich wirklich. Ich will dich nicht blamen dafür. Ich finde es auch Mist im Vergleich zu einer VM im Fullscreen.
Interessiert mich aber, warum du das so siehst.
Vielleicht finde ich noch ein paar neue Arguments, wenn es mal wieder um WSL geht.
WSL 2 ist schon viel, viel besser als WSL 1.
Die zugrunde liegende Technik ist halt komplett anders.
Aber insgesamt ja, gerade mit WSLG und solchen Sachen ist es schon deutlich angenehmer jetzt.
Die VM läuft dann in VMware Workstation. Nicht als VMware Workstation, in VMware Workstation.
VMware Workstation ist die Virtualisierung-Software, wo ich mir mal einen Key gekauft habe für 8€ bei irgendeinem billigen Key-Shop.
Also, ihr müsst nicht das bezahlen bei VMware in irgendwie 250€.
Chainlore willst du wieder gebannt werden, weil du irgendwelche Links... Keine Links posten!
Sobald der Chainlore komische Sachen postet, einfach direkt Timeout wieder.
Direkt, ja. Oder gleich. Genau, so muss das sein.
Den ganzen Scheiß weg da.
Ne, lass ihn, lass ihn, lass ihn ruhig, lass ihn ruhig.
Aber das war gut, dass der Kram gelöscht ist. Ich hab echt keinen Bock, dass es da mal irgendwie Probleme gibt.
Ich erinnere mich noch.
Wir suchen einen Physio und finden keinen.
Ja, das ist doch genau richtig für Ambulance. Da ist er doch.
Let's go. Woblos Jobvermittlung.
Ja, ja, Provisionen in Prime Subs oder in normalen Subs.
Wie gesagt, kann auch in Subscription bezahlt werden, meine Provision.
Ja, Gaming ist auch unter Linux nix. Ich weiß, es gibt genug Leute, die erzählen dir das Gegenteil.
Und ja, wenn du Glück hast, dass du nur das spielen willst, was gut funktioniert.
Es funktioniert ja mittlerweile auch im Vergleich zu früher erstaunlich viel, ist das okay.
Aber so als reines oder als jemand, der viel spielt und halt auch moderne, frische Releases, wird nicht so wirklich glücklich unter Linux.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Babagun hat einen gekriegt.
Kennt jemand Hyper-V? Ja, WSL läuft in Hyper-V.
Ansonsten kenne ich niemanden, der Hyper-V ernsthaft benutzt für was anderes als WSL.
Aber die gibt es, weil letztens habe ich das mal gefragt im Chat und es gab wirklich welche.
Guck hier, zum Beispiel der Marc, die haben sowas.
Unverständlicherweise, aber wahrscheinlich, wenn man viel Windows virtualisiert, macht es vielleicht Sinn.
Android Studio läuft ohne Probleme. Ja.
Haben wir sogar installiert, glaube ich, oder?
Haben wir nicht Android Studio? Ne, habe ich wieder deinstalliert.
Wir haben Android Studio laufen lassen, wir mussten mal. Sogar der Emulator läuft gut.
Der Windows VM ist ja auch verkehrt herum, deswegen auch Linux VM.
Okay, Erfahrungsbericht von Nico.
Ich habe vor einem Monat meinen Arbeitgeber gewechselt und mir fallen jetzt erst viele Dinge auf, die sehr kurios waren.
Da geht es dir wie mir.
Manche Sachen, die ich für, mir fällt jetzt leider kein konkretes Beispiel ein, aber es gibt immer wieder kleine Sachen,
die ich für ganz normal hielte, waren so unternehmensspezifische Eigenheiten.
Unternehmensspezifische Eigenheiten.
Die gibt es dort, wo ich jetzt bin, sicherlich auch, aber die fallen mir jetzt vom alten Arbeitgeber erst erst richtig auf.
Was ist deine Meinung dazu?
Ich war Software...
Was ist ein SW?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ein SW ist.
Software?
Entwickler? Ne.
Okay, Softwareentwickler.
Für die Prozessautomatisierung mit immer wieder eher nebensächlichen kleinen Inhouse-Entwicklungen für Kunden.
Jedoch wurde uns konsequent gesagt, dass es unser Geschäftsmodell wäre, Inhouse-Entwicklungen zu verkaufen und wir uns damit selbst finanzieren würden.
Hä? Das ist mir zu high IQ, das kann ich heute Abend nicht beantworten.
Du hast nebensächlich Sachen dort entwickelt. Widerspricht sich Inhouse und Verkaufen nicht eigentlich?
Oder sind das so Dinge wie, wir haben Inhouse was entwickelt und das hat sich dann als gut herausgestellt, wir können es doch auch verkaufen und...
Ich weiß nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll, keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
Kein Schimmer.
Mach mal ne Umfrage.
Bin zu faul.
Ich geh jetzt gleich ins Bett, ich bin zu faul, irgendwas einzutippen.
Wenn ich gerade einen am Mordsbock hab, mach ich jetzt keine Umfrage.
Magst du eins trinken? Ja, sehr gut.
Docker in WSL, ja das geht, aber in der VM ist es trotzdem immer noch angenehmer.
Hast du schon das Passwort-Game gespielt?
Ne.
Was ist das Passwort-Game?
Ich hab das auf Steam, ein Passwort-Game.
Heute ein Angebot bekommen als Senior Windows-Admin.
Ja was denn du?
70 bis 80k.
Also, je nachdem welche Branche und wo du bist, würde ich sagen, ist das für ne Senior-Stelle, untere Grenze.
Also die 70k.
Chainlore, jetzt muss ich dich schon wieder timern, dass der Mist verschwindet.
Was soll das?
Ich bin zu faul, ihn jetzt zu timern.
Ich weiß schon, Chainlore, warum du überall gebannt bist.
Oder den 500. Discord-Account hast.
Torflip, danke für den Sub.
Max, wann kommt der erste Kubernetes-Operator mit...
Ich wüsste nicht, wozu ich einen eigenen Kubernetes-Operator bauen soll.
So, ich wollte jetzt noch einen Blick in diese Stellenanzeigen werfen, weil irgendjemand geschrieben hat,
das ist die Schlimmste, die er je gesehen hat.
Also, auf geht's.
Unser Horizont ist keine Linie, sondern 360 Grad.
Damit aus Projekten Welten werden.
Wir wagen uns auf Wege, bevor sie existieren.
Ist das Philosophie aus Chat-GPT?
Als mehrfacher Gewinner des German Design Award, ist das so viel wert wie der deutsche Videospielpreis?
Oder taugt das was?
Chat, wisst ihr das?
Red Dot Award, IF Design Award, wurden wir für diesen Mut belohnt.
Begleite uns auf diesem Weg und werde mit uns zum Pionier.
Okay, ich mein, das ist schon mal eine gute Idee.
Ich muss Angst haben, abgestochen zu werden.
Bitte formuliere einen Satz, der Sinn ergibt, Niko.
Dann kann ich da auch was zu sagen.
Also, zumindest finden sie sich geil.
Das habe ich schon mal rausbekommen.
Ach, du meinst, du liest das da oben vor?
Blender, C Sharp, Linux, ja, C++, OpenGL.
Ja, ja, ja.
Linux, ja, C, C++, OpenGL, Unity, Unreal, Windows Desktop System.
Wow, what?
Oh, ich glaube, das ist sowas, was man sich mal safen muss im Zweifelsfall.
Deine Aufgaben.
Du übernimmst die allgemeine Softwareentwicklung C, C++, C Sharp, WPF, UWP.
Die machen ja alles, Alter.
Das ist doch eine Verarschung, oder?
Das ist doch irgendeine Verarschung.
Du entwickelst 3D-Software in Unity, Unreal Engine, OpenGL Direct.
Das ist doch eine komplett...
Die veräppeln die Leute doch mit der Stellenanzeige, oder?
Du kümmerst dich um die Systemadministration unter Windows und Linux.
Das ist doch nicht ernst gemeint.
Das ist doch bestimmt Fake.
Du unterstützt das Team bei der Webentwick...
Das ist doch ein Troll-Post, Leute.
Das ist doch irgendeine Verarschung.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Wir gucken mal.
CosaLux in Offenbach.
Fuck, die gibt es wirklich?
Oder am Ende kommt...
Wir nehmen alle...
Das war nur ein Witz.
Lass mal gucken.
Webentwicklung.
Das muss ein Jebait sein.
Das ist schon zu offensichtlich.
Du erarbeitest Hardware-Lösungen, z.B. Platinen-Layout.
Du hilfst mit bei Hard- und Software-Prototyping, inklusive Löten.
Du planst und baust die IT-Infrastruktur mit auf.
Du gestaltest...
Das ist eine richtig geile Anzeige, wenn die unten drunter schreiben...
Ach nee, Jebaited, bewirb dich einfach bei uns.
Du planst und baust die IT-Infrastruktur.
Du assistierst dem 3D-Team beim Modellieren und Rendern.
Reddit und Steam sind dein Zuhause.
Das Linux-Betriebssystem ist dir genauso vertraut wie Counter-Strike.
Freunde bezeichnen dich als Löten-Ludwig oder Bios-Bernd.
Das muss Fake sein bzw. ein Trick, dass man sich bewirbt,
weil unten drunter steht, wir suchen genau dich.
Widerstände sind für dich Bauteil, nicht nur politische Bewegungen.
Du bist handwerklich so begabt, dass du das Dragon-Raumschiff
mit einem Schweizer Taschen... Was ist denn das Dragon-Raumschiff?
Von Shane Entwicklung schränkst du dich zurück.
Das muss Jebaited sein, aber ein guter Jebaited.
Hoffentlich haben die auch den Obstkorb.
Bewirb dich jetzt, hau in die Tasten, melde dich bei uns.
Schick uns deinen Lebenslauf.
Okay, los geht's bei 8.
Moment.
Ich habe wirklich fest damit gerechnet,
dass der jetzt irgendwo steht.
Das war nur ein Witz, aber irgendwie so ein cooler Twist.
Nein, das meinen die nicht ernst.
Das können die nicht ernst meinen.
Das muss Jebaited sein.
Das ist irgendein Marketing-Laden.
Das ist 100 Prozent ein Marketing-Gag.
Das geht nicht anders.
Mal gucken, was die für Kununu-Bewerbungen haben.
Typisch Marketing-Agentur.
Okay, Jobs.
Die lösen das auf auf ihrer Webseite.
Okay.
Wo denn?
Ich glaube nicht, dass das ernst gemeint ist.
Das liest sich einfach zu durchdacht Jebaited.
Aber trotzdem, Hut ab.
Ich finde es gut.
Nicht die Stellenanzeige als Stellenanzeige.
Das ist eine gute Taktik.
Aber spätestens hier mit dem Lötkolben ist es vorbei.
Das ergibt ja wirklich keinen Sinn.
Kannst du die Url reinschreiben?
Ja.
Es ist doch ganz normal, dass man das Url ausspricht.
Ich meine, kann das auch Url oder Url oder was auch immer ich sage.
Url.
Ich bin ja nicht der Einzige, der das so ausspricht.
Die Frage ist auch eher, sagst du Gif oder Jif?
Oder Jason?
Oder Jezon?
Was ja laut dem ursprünglichen Erfinder eher die korrekte Aussprache ist.
Oder Java oder Java.
Oder Jira oder Jaira.
Wir hatten mal jemanden bei uns auf der Arbeit, der musste alles super krass aussprechen.
Der hat nicht Jira gesagt und auch nicht Jaira.
Der hat irgendwie sowas gesagt wie Jaira oder sowas.
Ganz vieres Zeug.
Aber ist es ein Router oder ein Rauter?
Für mich ist es ein Router.
Für die Amis bei Cisco ist es ein Rauter.
Deswegen ist es ja auch die Route 66.
Wie sagst du zu SQL?
Nicht Sequel.
Korrekt.
Falls du von einer Fritzbox sprichst.
Gibt es das?
In diesem Video nur ganz kurz.
Ja, ist die bessere Variante.
BTRFS oder Beta oder ButterFS oder wie auch immer man das nennen will.
Du meinst das mit dem Klo?
Nein, ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Ich habe es aber offen.
Das gucken wir uns das nächste Mal an.
Ich muss jetzt pennen, Leute.
Ich bin müde as fuck.
FSCK.
Wisst ihr?
Manchmal.
Mir fällt gerade auf, dass die Basu-Chan wenigstens ordentliches Weebilld hat.
Mir fällt gerade auf, dass ich tatsächlich oftmals mich dabei erwische, dass ich Checkdisk sage.
Anstatt FSCK.
Oder, oder.
Dein Bild traue ich mir gar nicht öffentlich im Stream anzugucken.
Das muss ich auf meinem Vorschau-Monitor anschauen.
Passt zu dir, Chandler, das Bild.
Ne, nein, nein, nein.
Das ist nicht Sebarro.
Auch wenn es sich ähnlich liest.
Sebarro ist gerade im Studiumsgrind.
Hat letztens was in den Admin-Chat geschrieben, den ihr nicht sehen konntet.
Aber dem Cute-Mod persönlich geht es ganz gut.
Okay, Leute, ich gehe jetzt auf.
Bis dann, macht's gut, tschau.